I was I mean I was dating a girl a while  back and it was just like and was it her  looks was she not no no no she was  really she was she was very cute  um and but she was just  she couldn't do enough I mean she'd  always make me breakfast in the morning  and she and then she'd make me and I  don't even eat breakfast so that was  kind of annoying I'm like listen I don't  really eat breakfast I like to just have  a coffee and then she comes oh and she'd  bring this you know the porridge is  piled up with fruit and then she's like  oh can I get you something else can I  get you can I do some eggs can I do some  eggs right no no no you know it's too  much too much